Mike you she had a group of kitchen is
no I doing it so excuse I to sit close
up when you make a net worth talking
mobility
I'm quite open yet this is not as
unusual seducer opening the manager
closer you're in the shot buddy I grew
up in Santa Cruz California i was born
in the stadia by Wilmington and Delaware
I grew up in a city called bangalore at
the end of the war second world war in
Vietnam and I can you nice take I'm not
ginger in Bavaria little town called
kanpur I grew up in Washington DC area
and buckles it's a small village in
Belgium it's like it's an illusion that
this is the land of milk and honey now
oh I think things were better before me
and my parents for example when I was my
daughter's age and she's 21 now I had a
job make a lot of money and she now
she's in college which is good but she
can't find a job and she get a job is
gonna pay a little bit of money anyway
and then when she graduates maybe she'll
get a job in her field and one day she'd
make a lot of money I disappear off a
bunch of loans for a country like India
where the population is 1 billion there
are so many people and so many different
kinds of people to provide the same kind
of opportunities there's a lot more
difficult and a lot more complicated but
yeah the opportunities in America much
more vast which is kind of why I'm here
I wanted to live in a bigger house than
them go to college have a hard-working
job
what money makes things easier obviously
obviously you know it's I mean they're
itching with the rich the poor hang with
the poor I definitely feel like it plays
a major part and who they are and who
they'll become your well level of wealth
does govern what you can afford to give
your kids but it is also important to
show that economic probe no advance it's
not the only progress in life I think
it's all about like education
family-wise indication education given
the opportunities and I'm kind of like
pushing through the opportunities have
better opportunities right now then your
dad didn't make one
no no have the same opportunity oh I did
better because um because I just went to
a better school we caught we come here
little little late we don't have no
chain that's why we got to do this and
you go up here you got to go finish to
us the high school and how Twitter could
call it kids came up my neighborhood you
know the option was military you cannot
college but I guess it depends on where
you're raised in different places and
they expected college but only they
force college they're very supportive in
whatever I wanted to do they have better
schools better opportunities they're not
influenced by drugs cane kids not going
to school it's not being cool to go to
school this is also something that you
cannot predict in the beginning you are
lucky or nothing to help them to develop
new you tie what you can it was a real
pleasure yeah I could go on and on okay
sounds pretty awesome glad I can help
you guys out okay yeah